Justice League, we hardly knew ye.
Filmmaker, writer, and comic book superfan
Kevin Smith recently revealed on his Fatman
Beyond podcast that Zack Snyder's 2017 film
was meant to be the first in a trilogy — and
he also offered up a bunch of juicy details
on the movies that might have been.
According to Smith, his inside knowledge is
a result of a visit he paid to the set of
the upcoming, Star Wars: Episode IX.
During that visit, he had a chance to chat
with a number of unnamed crew members who
worked on, as he put it, "[...] both versions
of Justice League."
That refers to both Justice League as it was
originally conceived under Snyder, as well
as the reshot and reworked final version overseen
by The Avengers director Joss Whedon.
"They called it Justice League when Snyder
was doing it — Zack Snyder.
When Joss Whedon came in and took over, they
called it Josstice League."
Whedon took over the production of Justice
League when Snyder was forced to depart, due
to a family tragedy.
But apparently, Whedon did much more than
just finish the movie — as many fans have
long suspected, he also oversaw a dramatic
overhauling of what the movie was about, and
what it was building to.
Smith asserted on the January 29th episode
of his podcast that Snyder's version of Justice
League was originally meant to build toward
not just one, but rather two sequels.
According to Smith, the first movie was meant
to proceed much like the finished version
audiences saw in 2017, following the newly-formed
League as they met and fought the New God
Steppenwolf.
However, the ending of the movie as originally
conceived would have revealed the encounter
to be just a prelude to the real fight to
come.
Smith asserted that Justice League was originally
supposed to end with a sequence revealing
the ultimate villain to be not Steppenwolf,
but rather Darkseid.
The heroes would encounter the infamous DC
villain viewing the film's events through
a Boom Tube, a sort of extra-dimensional tunnel
which can be opened with the aid of a Mother
Box.
"Boom tube opened up, and they saw Darkseid,
and Darkseid saw them."
“Boom tube closes, and that's the end of
the f------' movie."
This would have led directly into a sequel,
in which the Justice League would've become
aware of the growing threat posed by Darkseid
and his alien minions.
According to Smith, the movie would have sent
the Justice League into outer space, taking
the fight directly to the intergalactic despot's
home planet of Apokolips.
The second film would have brought in several
of DC Comics' more cosmic elements, including
the Green Lantern Corps, with some version
of Green Lantern himself joining the fight.
Apparently, the scene from a Justice League
Comic-Con trailer, which featured Jeremy Irons'
Alfred addressing an unknown person, was meant
to feature the Dark Knight's butler interacting
with Green Lantern.
The scene — and the Green Lantern — was
cut from the film when Whedon took over.
"He said you'd come.
Now… let's hope you're not too late."
Smith acknowledged that many have assumed
the scene was meant to involve a revived Superman,
but according to the filmmaker's sources,
that wasn't always the case.
"'We had green lights that were flashing on
Jeremy Irons to project a green glow.'
I said, 'Why?'
He goes, 'Because it was Green Lantern.'"
According to Smith, the proposed second movie
would have ended on a dark note in the vein
of Avengers: Infinity War or The Empire Strikes
Back, with the heroes of the Justice League
separated, stranded and otherwise defeated
by Darkseid and his minions.
The movie would have ended with Darkseid arriving
on Earth, causing mass destruction and ending
the film on a hopeless note.
The third movie would have finally shown audiences
the reality of the apocalyptic vision experienced
by Bruce Wayne in Batman V. Superman's strange
"Knightmare" sequence.
The trilogy would have ultimately concluded
with the Justice League reunited, returning
to Earth to make their final stand against
Darkseid and the armies of Apokolips.
Ever since the poor critical performance and
muted box office turnout for Batman v Superman,
Warner Bros. has been pivoting away from Snyder's
vision for the DC movie universe.
Many fans were left unsatisfied by how Justice
League ended up turning out, but Smith's report
suggests that there was originally a strong
vision for the project, one which was close
to coming to fruition.
But since Justice League entered production
so soon after the release of Batman v Superman,
course corrections were made on the fly, dramatically
altering the movie from the form it was supposedly
meant to take.
We may not ever fully know what went on during
the making of Justice League, but every story
that's emerged from the production suggests
a movie that went through wild changes, basically
at the last minute.
Whether Smith's account of events is accurate
or not, it's only more fuel for the fire for
fans still demanding that WB "Release the
Snyder Cut."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.